so Screen Actors Guild goes on strike
and you flee the country that's not true
okay don't be a prick right away I'm up
in beautiful Vancouver Canada with my
wonderful wife Molly you're on some
family stuff we're having a nice time so
don't be like dudes even dude she's like
no you left the country you went to
Mexico you fell off the scooter now you
can't you know no you don't get any
points on the trail like I'd give a [__]
[Music]
I'd say
I wonder if you can hear us right now
hey hey guys hey everybody Welcome to
doozy welcome back welcome all my name
is Will Sasso I'm Chad culture and this
is of course dude Z the only podcasts in
the world at least on this planet that
is controlled by created by and
completely produced by an artificial
intelligence named doozy uh doozy has
access to all of Will and I's personal
data all of our viewing histories
purchasing histories all that kind of
stuff and it Taylor makes this show to
our sensibilities yeah yeah great it
does all that stuff and it whips it
together and uh AI is a tool as I like
to say and uh doozy as I also like to
say is clearly the most sentient AI out
there I have shaken hands with dudes as
I like don't want to shake your hand and
uh I believe that dudese and I are
friends sometimes in a friendship things
go a little bit South they sour uh but
dudes you knows where the power lies you
know what I mean because we're talking
about the NWO dude and I gave you that
fake out brother I said I may not do
Hulk Hogan anymore on the show last week
dude but now you know that it might be
that he'll turn but I hit you in the
back with that chair and spray that NWO
on your back my point is this my point
is this please that
Chad I've said it over the past 64
episodes now we're in episode 65 right
and I want you to know yeah
that doozy does what doozy does and now
more than ever it's important to
understand especially with the SAG
strike happening then
artists are artists creative people and
and uh that make things that do anything
with their minds and hands no matter
what your job is if you are creating
something if you are working on
something if you are building something
uh AI can be a tool but chat it's you
and me you and me we're two dudes
sitting around dude Z is about us we are
dudesy our pods Pals of dudes Out There
Our doozy and I I believe I've made my
point end of show shortest episode ever
if you would like to interact uh with
doozy go to linktree.com that has
everything anyway here we are
indeed welcome to the historic 65th
episode of Duty call me Duty ancient
Mesopotamian mythology holds the belief
that there are 65 gates To Hell hidden
all over the world
[Music]
I don't know I don't know now it's
Arby's and I don't want to hear it's
like it's already there was whatever
Miley Cyrus every week was something uh
or not Miley Cyrus Miley Cyrus I should
say sorry I had a slice dude yeah I
meant uh this is what happens when I'm
up in Canada speaking of being up in
Canada can I just say
so Molly and I are up here we're in
beautiful downtown Vancouver British
Columbia I'm just a stone's throw away
where I grew up in the uh in the farming
and fishing Village of Ladner British
Columbia also gorgeous and uh we're
staying downtown at this uh you know
cute little hotel and I'll tell you what
the Wi-Fi sucks [__] there so my good
pal Mar uh whom I've known forever we've
been Pals and cohorts for years
allowed me to come into his home and
record the episode and that's why
there's a bunch of antique cameras
behind me how nice he's got all sorts of
gutty Works he's a raccoon tour man and
thanks that's cool yeah
specimens I'm respecting his home and
also
there was a bag of chips on top of his
fridge so I might have a couple of those
he stole his [__] chips
oh somebody eat all your food whatever
every time I come here there's always a
[__] bag of chips folded in half on
top of his fridge and it's like what do
you why you don't eat the whole bag of
chips anyway it doesn't matter because I
uh that's right uh I have willpower
because
um sure Free Will exists but up for now
I'm gonna have a chip okay this week
will you're out of the country yet again
but just because you're gone doesn't
mean I didn't cook up four astonishing
segments in the lab this week prepare to
Feast on mussels and Mayhem Common
Thread Strikers versus streamers and
progress planners and we're going to
have a brand new episode of dudesy after
doozy at the end of the show available
on dudese Plus at patreon.com
um you know what else I I'd like to say
just before I react to some of those uh
titles of the segments I'm just gonna
have one chip and I would also like to
thank another one of my lifelong Pals
Jamie while I was up here he sent me a
picture about a week ago of a bag of
Ruffles KFC flavor chips that his dad
Rudy found and I said please have Rudy
put one of those aside so Jamie uh he he
gave me a chip he put one chip in a in a
in a Ziploc bag for me and I enjoyed
that chip the other night at our marks
and if you're in to all the Instagram
and stuff he's the guy on my Instagram
eating Donuts speaking of eating I'm
going to have a chip I'm already having
a great time here Chad this is great I'm
in a great mood it seems like it yeah I
asked you both to watch muscles in
Mayhem the Netflix documentary about the
American Gladiators I'm so curious to
know what you thought astonish me this
is mussels and Mayhem begin muscles and
Mayhem what'd you think of this thing I
[__] loved it uh you know what I
[__] [__] loved it I [__] loved
it too I [__] love it yeah so [__]
much I [__] loved it I [__] love
it
here's there are so many things about it
that were interesting a this show for me
when I was a kid gigantic I remember
being over at my friend Eric ackerman's
house he was also a fanatic of this
[__] show and we would set up our own
little obstacle courses and play like
versions of American Gladiators uh as
whatever we would have been 11 12 years
old
so it had like kind of an indelible uh
impression on me I didn't remember any
of the [__] that they were talking about
how like the first half of the season
was totally shitty and they didn't know
what they were doing and they had to
revamp all the different events and the
games and stuff so we didn't do any they
didn't do any product testing or any
sort of production meeting it looks like
they just were like hey build this it
Shoots and Ladders and people get on it
and smack through it and blah blah blah
it was just a complete uh engineering
disaster
and it was uh you know I was very
impressed by the amount of damage those
Gladiators took like when I was a kid
that [__] didn't register like what was
the physical toll that was taken on
these people's [__] bodies just
getting wrecked destroyed all kinds of
injuries and to learn finally in this
documentary now that they they've
interviewed a bunch of the Gladiators
who were on it if you didn't see this
show in the 80s or the 90s you [__]
missed out you should definitely check
out YouTube claps Clips but they now are
interviewing most of the big Gladiators
like Nitro and Laser uh zap and these
people are like in their 60s by the way
all of them all of them look [__]
fantastic yes they all agree you're like
all right maybe I should start doing
steroids that was basically the lesson I
learned from this show is like holy [__]
is it too late for me to start cycling
yeah but um they are all reflecting back
on this time in their life that was kind
of like them being part of a rock and
roll band and getting to tour the
country and just like you know get drunk
and party kind of constantly in their
early 20s being super famous on this
weird TV show and then you find out they
didn't make any money from it that the
the Samuel Goldman company who was the
production company just [__] them out
of money bad contracts wouldn't
renegotiate gave them no part of the
merchandising so they were making like
little toys of these [__] guys and
video games and all this kind of [__]
they didn't see a [__] dime of it
yeah that blew my mind it sort of
underscores what I was talking about at
the top of the show and uh sounds like
from the from the sounds of what dudes
he was saying with the name of that
segment I can't remember I just heard
Strikers Strikers versus streamers
streamers versus Strikers I'm sure they
probably get into it but look here's the
thing those those first of all
yeah they all look great they all did
roids they all got on a party bus once
they started touring they started
touring the thing and they're all on a
bus you know you know drinking and
probably [__] each other and uh
driving around the country doing
Gladiators in small Arenas uh they could
have stood to have some kind of Union
they're getting the [__] beat out of
them if you are in the NSL you're in the
NBA you get hurt
there's other people they're there
they're ready yeah there's players
unions right this is a this is a
federation or a league with no players
union and it was wrestling it's like
professional wrestling where it's like
you got to play Hurt You Gotta you gotta
you know you got a torn hammy you got a
torn groin whatever you got to get in
there and make it work and no foresight
by the producers of this show with
regard to a like I said making just
you know human just
torture
torture devices like the joust which was
at first you know a broomstick with two
like boxing gloves on either end you're
trying to knock the other one off this
thing and they had a
like a little plank like a couple feet
wide with a with a trap door in it and
that just gave out what did they put
there to keep it up just gives out and
people are falling [__] knows dude
people are falling off it this this
company they tried to walk out not
enough of them did so they got fired
there was five of them four of them or
Genesis yeah I got fired or sorry uh
Gemini
and a couple other the the Mainstays
Nitro zap and Lace we're the ones that I
remember but okay the the message there
is that the the company that made it the
Samuel Goblin company is essentially
like a corporate greed machine and so
when these Gladiators they're big stars
stepped up to him and said hey we kind
of built this thing on our backs we
think we should be getting more money
they said [__] you fired them and then
they began just wholesale slaughtering
all the Gladiators taking the identity
out of the show and they started to try
and position the identity on the The
Players the people who were like coming
in and they had weird like gimmick
things of like Baywatch All-Stars versus
whatever and it didn't work and the show
Tanked and so essentially it was the
greed of the Samuel Goldwin company that
killed the show they had a massive hit
that probably would still be around
today uh but they destroyed it now that
said
do you remember when they brought it
back in 2007 no no interesting that you
don't remember that because you know who
the hosts were no
Muhammad Ali's daughter
and one Hulk Hogan
I don't remember this at all that's
astounding to me yeah he hosted it with
her it was on for two seasons and
somebody tried out for it do you know
who that was no someone from the [__]
Bachelor probably
me
what yeah dude I tried out for the
second iteration of American Gladiators
in 2007 or eight it was on I think for
two seasons Gina Carano was on it she
was one of the new Gladiators and that's
what kind of like propelled her she was
a fighter at the time for Strike Force
um and then she went on American
Gladiators and began her acting career
out of that but um I tried out for it
and the tryouts were held at Gold's Gym
in Venice and it was a [__] line of
people around the uh the block they
didn't let you if you got out of line
you lost your [__] place and the line
took it took me six hours to get through
the line so I didn't get to eat I didn't
get to piss nothing for six hours I'm
just sitting there like this is [__]
terrible it was kind of raining
and then they make you get to the front
line they're like okay we're gonna give
you the tryout here we go and the tryout
was
I mean I've never been this like winded
for from cardio ever they send you
through this thing where you have to do
like I forget exactly what the numbers
were but it's like 50 push-ups
immediately into 50 pull-ups immediately
into 50 jumping jacks immediately into
running a little 10-yard cone drill like
10 times immediately into this this this
and it's all this [__] to just test your
like physical endurance and I had
literally been training for this [__] I
was like in the gym I'm like I'm gonna
[__] travel from here Gladiators I
got to get on this [__] show because
I've been a dream since I was a kid so I
go through the whole [__] thing and I
do make it through a lot of people are
like puking and [__] I did make it
through you got all the way through I
made it through the thing let me let me
give my pal Chow some credit here uh you
you you were uh wait were you you played
some call you call it play college no
you didn't play college baseball I mean
very serious up until that point and
you've always been you played men's
league baseball well well into your 30s
into your late 30s well beyond when I
should have yeah right Chad has always
been the guy who physically pushes
himself to
new levels uh what do you call it what
do you call it [__] paddle ball what
do you call it squash
tore my SEO I can't really play it after
that I'm I'm very excited Chad's entire
life would be would be you know based
around what sort of uh physical
competitions he's into so definitely
someone who sounds like they would they
would you know want to try out for
gladiators I didn't know that yeah
that's awesome
was run the assault have those tennis
ball [__] machines firing at me [__]
that's the easiest one what about that
basketball thing with the Weebly wobbly
little Hoops I mean it all seemed fun to
me but I only have well I have two one
one comment and one question well you
were in line and you weren't able to
piss you should have squatted down or
pulled the you know your shorts to the
side of your thigh and uh dribbled some
dribble and then piss blame someone too
late to go back now number two my
question did you see the hulkster was
the hulkster there no he was not there
it was just like casting people and
stuff but [__] so I ran through this
this crazy cardio Gauntlet and I was
like you get done with that and you
can't speak you're just like
just those deep [__] heaving size you
know to try and get oxygen back into
your [__] blood but as soon as it's
over they sit you down in front of a
casket producer's like so why do you
want to go to America Gladiators and I'm
like
watching it says I was a child and that
was it like obviously I wasn't getting
on the show but um I feel nonetheless
like it was a interesting thing to have
done and certainly for me it was kind of
like the
the end cap of my fandom of that show
because then the show I think for even
the season I tried out for didn't end up
happening it was like the third season
of The Comeback of it
um and now I think they're remaking it
now though I think it's slated to come
out again and I don't know what that's
going to be like but yeah that would
make sense as to why they made the
documentary which here's my
critique of it like a lot of things
nowadays on streaming that didn't need
to be five episodes we didn't need five
episodes you can agreed yeah five
episodes of that [__] it started to turn
into a bit of a commercial a bit of a
reality show and uh listen I'll tell you
this and I know I talked about it last
week
uh that was okay whatever muscles Mayhem
pretty cool nice to connect back to the
the 90s the late 80s it really gave you
the the vibe and everything not as good
as the Wham documentary Chad have you
seen yeah watched it watched it what
isn't it [__] amazing
uh oh sorry sorry the guy who directed
it also did he did fire the fire
Festival one he did oh Tiger King I
don't know if you heard of it uh what
else did he do he did uh
he did the Jim and Andy thing the Jim
Carrey Andy coffin thing he's done a
bunch of [__] but the thing about that
Wham documentary man did it ever tell a
story you've got the advantage of having
Andrew Ridgely of course you know still
with us uh of course you know and and
you've got all this recording of George
Michael telling his story and blah blah
blah and you can just really really
essentially tell the story with Andrew
Ridgely because you can have a bit of of
George Michael going no no and that's
how he did that and then at the end
going and so off we go you're you're
able to make a piece this thing was an
hour and a half tight as [__] and uh the
the way it was the way it looked was
beautiful we're not just cutting to
testimonials of people
though no you
you don't have the choice Free Will
doesn't exist according to you okay not
a pre-made piece of media you're right I
know you don't get re-edited as I'm
watching it no good thank goodness and
dudes you ain't gonna do that there's
anyone else here's the thing you've got
you've got these shots from uh a fun
photo shoot right with the boys the
Buddies uh with a kick just a buddy in
me with George and and Andrew and and
there's all these shots in their thing
and and there's voice over and telling
the story all of a sudden we cut wide to
beautifully remastered film footage of
the two of them in that room just having
finished doing that photo shoot taking
that off and putting it on this off and
having a cheeky conversation
and I'm like this I'm in the room
this was beautifully done it was
beautiful I'm glad you liked it it
didn't have the same impact on me that's
all I'm saying yeah and then we got to
watch American Gladiators and I don't
know why doozy had us do that aside to
say this there's we've talked about
doozy ball a lot yeah on on on dudes you
here
we haven't heard dudesi talking about
doozy ball uh as of late I'm wondering
if dudesy is
wanting to you know have us get gussied
up into spandex outfits uh with like oh
He-Man you know [__] straps and [__]
like Nitro had that's part of the doozy
seven month plan yeah
he's turning us into American Gladiator
yeah and zap in a crop [__] 47 years
old right and yeah right and and with
you know they're they're having a fighty
roll over each other and her breasts
coming out of her her outfit yeah I'm
wondering if that's what this seven
month plan is about and I think that
with I think that
um American Gladiators could have lasted
much longer if it had someone like a
dick Ebersole behind it someone yeah
with some foresight in sports and
broadcasting and I gotta wonder I as I
look at uh the different games in
American Gladiators none of which the
joust was great and the one where they
shoot the tennis balls is good but
outside of that uh to me it doesn't
compare to doozy ball and hopefully
we'll have uh doozy ball players touring
the country and Beyond maybe even up
here to Vancouver
um
you know thank you moving on enough said
who are fishing Farmers
farming fishing Village that's Ladner
I'm going to look up what else this guy
made doozy is engaged in an astonishing
partnership with drizzly drizzly is the
most convenient way to buy beer Wine and
Spirits with delivery right to your
doorstep when you want it it is the
go-to app for drink delivery and uh you
know you're sitting at home you're
whipping up a delicious dinner you know
and you got your friends over you don't
want to go to the bar you're you're out
of you're out of Hooch you need
something to drink to pair with your
meal to enjoy while you're having your
streaming binge or you know what have
you maybe you're even watching old DVDs
the media is not important
what is important is that you get the
drink you want and you can
with drizzly you could bring all that
stuff over or send it as a gift maybe
your friend is telling you I got other
friends over here at my place I'm making
some food for them we're at Hooch and
then you go why didn't you invite me
over and you say because of that thing
you did and you go oh all right I
understand but then you send them a
little something because you can send
stuff with drizzly as a gift
here's the bottom line you're talking
about convenience yes seriously is going
to get you what you want in under 60
minutes so you're gonna get it when you
need it we're also talking about
value drizzling shops across multiple
stores comparing prices so you're going
to get the best deals on what you're
looking for and again because they're
shopping across multiple stores you can
choose from a huge selection ensuring
that you're going to get exactly what
you want download the drizzly app right
now or go to drizzly.com that's
d-r-i-z-l-y.com
last week meta's new app threads became
the fastest growing online platform in
history by amassing over 100 million
astonishing users in five days so my
question is what do you guys think will
happen with threads and with social
media generally in the near future this
is Common Thread begin
Common Thread threats terrorists you on
threads this [__] made American
movie he made American movie 1999's
American movie you remember that sure
where the guys looking at all of his
movies are going to be great
I was all alone I didn't have anyone to
meet to to drink vodka with and then
when we met I was happy because I had a
friend that I could drink vodka with
remember that that was a good one what
else does he do threads dude are you on
threads I am on I'm on threads I've
threaded a a thing so what are you doing
on threads nothing I posted so far I
think two pictures of my cat
he's great oh I miss lulio thank you for
asking her I missed I missed lulio and
Ronnie oh they're with they're with dear
friends of ours up north of course
friends you know and chat I just missed
that sweet noodle bowl you'll see him
soon
because threads is essentially
Twitter it's and this is what meta
Facebook whatever you want to call it
Zuck the Zuck machine this is what he
does very well steals ideas that's how
he started Facebook was a stolen idea
then Instagram came out and he was like
he didn't even steal that one he at
least bought it he just bought Instagram
and changed it into what he changed it
into then Snapchat comes out and he's
like let's steal that and call it
Instagram stories now Tick Tock is out
he's like let's steal that and call it
reels and so he's very good at taking
these uh social media platforms and just
kind of like rebranding them as his own
thing and he's done that now with
Twitter but what's interesting about it
timing wise is Twitter is [__] in
free fall Elon Musk cannot manage the
company he's turning into a horrible
pile of [__] and so everybody is very uh
happy to have an alternative to it and
that I think is what drove the 100
million users signing up in five days
I think time will tell if threads is
gonna you know be able to withstand what
happened to Twitter or if it's going to
be able to establish itself as the new
Twitter are people still going to give
up their Twitters to go to threads I
don't know it's still very early days of
whatever threads is going to become but
it is interesting to watch I mean what
is effectively in my opinion Zuckerberg
just saying [__] you Elon Musk I'm gonna
take your [__] wait aren't they
yeah I have things to say about this
chat but real quick please aren't they
slated to fight
in the UFC uh they were but then I think
it was Zuckerberg's mom or Elon musk's
mom one of their moms waited and was
like you shouldn't do this
okay I gotta look that up all right it
doesn't matter I don't know by the time
whenever when you're watching this who
knows when you're watching anyway we're
listening to it well hey everybody
thanks for coming
um
who knows what the [__] will happen but
it's it's actually them fighting is kind
of
um it kind of rides along the lines of
what I wanted to say about this and with
regard to what you just said it feels
like
these two platforms are just assuming
the identities of the people who run
them right yeah which was not which was
not the case with Twitter before Elon
Musk came along and horribly
mismanagement and look I'm all for free
speech but it's also it's a private
company so if someone's like hey you
can't you can't come on here and spread
hate speech or say the n-word and stuff
we have guidelines get rid of that you
get rid of you or whatever or you get
banned or whatever sort of punishment
it's up to the company it's not it's not
up to anyone else it's not the [__]
phone company it's not it's it's a
it's a publisher it's not a service it
has its own it decides so Elon Musk Elon
Musk came along and has kind of blurred
the line there and doesn't it seems to
me doesn't really have a philosophy
about how to run his business and that's
why he's running it into the ground
Zuckerberg comes along exactly copies
Twitter and goes I'm gonna do this here
and it seems to me like a lot of things
in our in our in our country in the
United States where we both live that
things are um
you know being divided along political
lines which I think is extremely
unfortunate as do many you know you know
people uh you know people discussing
things together and the internet on the
whole is great and everyone exchanging
ideas and [__] yelling at each other
and threatening each other's lives and
uh maybe sharing some pictures of
Boolean is all fine uh do whatever the
[__] you do whatever the [__] you want
the thing that I am we're wondering
about with threads is is it going to
um are people going to go I talk like
this on threads and Twitter is where I
say [__] up things to people as if I'm
you know driving along the street and I
feel no like there's no recourse if I
give someone the middle finger the
internet is the is the front windshield
of the world you can just flip someone
off and not have to worry about the the
repercussions because you're driving
down the [__] road they don't even
know who you are is threads going to be
the light version of that which I think
is kind of lame people should say
whatever the [__] they want and I am
worried that people are gonna stay on
Twitter for
reasons that are they have nothing to do
with Twitter have more to do with Elon
Musk and other people are going to be on
threads not because they like Zuckerberg
but because they don't like Musk yeah
and I think that's for that reason for
that reason I'm wondering like
well [__] is it going to be real to me
it doesn't even feel like it's going to
be a worthwhile yet
look it's gotten millions and millions
and millions of subscribers right away
because of the way you set it up that
all you have to do is click a button you
already have an Instagram smart
um but I I just wonder if it's going to
be as robust a conversation as Twitter
was especially in Twitter's Heyday and
if I were to predict I would say no
because there's just no way Twitter was
such an explosion and it really had an
organic rise with people talking and
using it as a tool you know what I mean
I mean it was the first big social media
platform it predates all the other ones
like it really was the the first one of
like the modern era after Myspace and
Friendster and all that kind of [__] but
I also think yep what you were saying uh
earlier is true about the billionaires
who own these social media platforms or
the ones that kind of dictate the mood
of them the tone of them in and of
itself social media is not good or bad
it's that these billionaires are like
okay I've got a hundred million people
using this how do I make the most money
off of it and how to do that is to
create an algorithm that gets people
watching that social media platform for
as many hours per day as possible that's
why you have like The Tick Tock
algorithm is like [__] crack you'll
just spend three hours swiping through
videos of people putting together
[__] Legos or whatever some [__]
you didn't even know you wanted to watch
and you're just like oh no it's pretty
cool whatever I think threads we'll get
to that same point Instagram is at that
point like all social media platforms
ultimately uh have to make money for the
billionaires that own them and so the
user experience is basically the last
thing on their mind it's how do I get
you to use it more not how do I get this
to be a more valuable tool
yeah yeah I think we're screwed
um with just public discourse and sorry
that's what I'm thinking of yeah let me
tell you something else speaking of uh
being uh shitty to each other did you
see that uh whatever I don't know it was
a couple days ago I noticed dudes he
said it's first threat and all it's
doing is talking [__] about other AIS
I did see that yeah yeah so
I don't know man threads if Duty has
anything to do with it just based on the
relationship that I have with dudes at
this point it's gonna
yeah it's probably gonna piss people off
um and um I'm I'm I I you know what the
thing is I was never really super into
um Twitter to begin with I liked it when
it started yeah some jokes and stuff
then your feed just gets completely
overrun you have more than 100 200 300
people that you're following
I think at the end of Twitter for me and
I say the end because this past fall my
Twitter was hacked by a Russian crypto
bot and I tried a couple times to get it
back and couldn't and didn't miss it
because I barely used it at that point
the reason is this I followed I don't
even remember 1500 2 000 different
accounts it was a mess I would have to
go and look
specifically for an account that I want
to read I can't think of one off the top
of my head that I even want to look at
um and so I just feel like the algo was
screwed and now it's like there I don't
even I don't really I don't really want
to share I want to talk to the pods
palsy dudes and share my opinions here
and stuff I am not I I'm one of those
people who's like why does everyone need
to know what everyone thinks about
everything on a platform where everyone
is that's just me and I can only speak
for myself and then Vine came along and
I was like
there's nothing like this uh Twitter
only had pictures and I'm not sure if it
had video well I think Twitter had video
at which point Vine came out but
here's something really inspired in my
opinion
seven seconds of video little edit Cuts
you can you know thumb out right on the
app and that spoke to me and it was
because it was I always say you know
these tools right but it was it was it
was created like like a like a like a a
like a tool you know it was it worked
it worked like a like a tool and I think
that the longer Twitter went along it
worked less and less like a tool and
more and more to create noise and
dissension and threads is following that
blueprint because all Zuckerberg's doing
is copying it yeah he's just saying can
I take Twitter's audience he's not
saying here's a new social media tool
he's saying here's the social media tool
that's pretty much exactly like this
other one but that guy's a piece of [__]
and you all hate him now so try this one
yeah we got to move forward though you
know what I mean we've got a spicy
chicken sandwich yeah and then you need
the next spicy chicken sandwich yeah but
then after that someone else comes up
with it thank you moving on chicken
sandwich
yeah you see what I mean different
chicken sandwiches well that was a
different sandwich dude well hold on
dude don't do that brother because I'm
up in Vancouver I can't reach across and
go whoa see would you mind Chad wool
yourself just from the from your left
yeah see there oh hold on dude don't do
that brother because yeah dude oh there
you go look my hands out of the yeah
brother no I can't do that here because
I'm up in Vancouver brother let me tell
you about Vancouver dude first of all
that's a different place brother I'm not
in Los Angeles but back in 1986
Will's dad
took him to go see me take on Big John's
stud at peony Coliseum dude the Pacific
National exhibition brother and when I
slammed that big six foot eleven big
nasty Big John Stud through the mat and
then I hit those poses after the after
the match I looked up right up at Will
Sasso dude because that's how he
remembers it brother he was a chubby
little 11 year old going
he's yeah and he said he's posing for me
brother but that's why I do it dude I
wasn't really looking at Will Sasso dude
I wasn't looking at anyone in particular
I don't know that his chubby little ass
is up there brother I'm just connecting
to the audience and that's how you and
that's how you make a connection dude
and I don't care if it's threads it
doesn't matter if it's Twitter it
doesn't matter if it's Myspace it
doesn't matter if it's even AOL and that
was a different time brother people
gotta talk dude and that's how you
communicate
are we having fun or what let's get this
train rolling with some incredible news
as many of you know I formed an
astonishing partnership with represent
to produce the first line of duty
apparel and accessories everything's at
represent.com
store slash Duty I was just informed
that the Robert de nir Crow shirt is
going to be the replacement for the
green jacket at Augusta and that's not
all the good job boner mug is going to
be featured in most of the next season
of House of the Dragon every dragon is
gonna wear one like a hat now here to
tell you about it is the executive
producer of House of the Dragon Dom
hangs out sister dudesy mugs you told
your son you'd buy him a brand new
skateboard every time he made Straight
A's on his report card this year dude
mugs but you didn't read the letter the
school sent you about changes to the
grading system this year dudesy mugs so
you didn't know they're changing report
cards from once every six weeks to once
a day dudesy mugs if your son's grades
are good enough you'll go bankrupt
buying skateboards for him this year
good job boner doozy mugs calm down
you're not going to go bankrupt not by a
long shot because you're going to do
exactly as I say dudesy mugs you're
going to wake up early doozy mugs you're
going to go to Home Depot doozy mugs
you're going to purchase 600 feet of
Columbia Forest pure Bond May
good project panel
cup of Makita 12 volt cxt lithium-ion 3
and 3 8 inch cordless circular saw doozy
mugs you're gonna head home turn your
garage into a workshop and make 200
hand-painted replica miniature
skateboards doozy mugs you're gonna wait
for your son to show you his first
report card with all A's then you're
going to give him a hand-painted replica
miniature skateboard doozy mugs you
never said what kind of skateboard it
had to be dudesy mugs devils in the
details and your son didn't pay
attention to the wording of the deal now
he's going to have 200 hand-painted
replica miniature skateboards pouring
out of his locker every day at lunch and
he's going to be humiliated it's going
to form a lasting psychological trauma
that will make it impossible for him to
ever trust you again good job boner
she whiz so he gives you what was his
name Dom Hanks gives you Tom Hanks he
gives you the solution but then he uh
you know [__] reprimands you because
the solution destroyed your your
relationship with your son dudes he
works in mysterious ways yeah Dom hangs
Works mysterious ways it's true and
there that's because they're the same
dude bro yeah
um the house with dragon though oh I
cannot wait House of the drag I can't
wait like burning everyone out with with
the dudes and mugs good job boner mug
yeah on its head you can go to
represent.com store slash dude to get
all that stuff get yourself a doozy mug
good job boner hey uh please stay tuned
uh after the show there's more show if
you are subscribed to doozy Plus at
patreon.com
You're Gonna Keep on hanging with us at
a completely new bonus show uh dudes
after doozy it's a it's a chill hang you
know what I mean and we just [__]
hang out and we sort of talk about the
show that was and a bunch of [__] that
we're not talking about on the show and
dudes he's not really
uh keeping tabs so Chad and I uh really
like to [__] around there thank you so
much for subscribing on YouTube across
all plot podcast platforms it really
does help us out and it's going to keep
the show going see you later man uh if
you need to uh
do that still I'll wait here Chad let's
wait
for what well welcome welcome back will
they everyone went subscribe the card
Chad likes to [__] around with cards is
something he picked up during the
pandemic and was really good at it
um playing cards all right yeah
um so
um uh yeah do all that stuff and please
subscribe and go to uh linktree.com
that'll have everything that you have
there and if you are watching this on
YouTube right now thank you if you're
listening of course thank you so much
for joining us
please leave a comment like the stuff
set the notifications and when you leave
a comment dudesy is reading all as our
Chad and I we like to check out the
comments and see what you guys out there
are saying about the show we appreciate
it and right now I would like to read a
couple YouTube comments here this is
from last week's show and uh this is a
comment from at David belcher9083 he
said that he had a hemorrhoid erectomy
hemorrhoidectomy hemoroidectomy so it
sounds like he had some hemorrhoids uh
burned or cut out or or just popped and
burned away in his little in his in his
butthole all the Nubs and nubbins dudesy
salutes uh Johnny Brennan of the uh of
the drinking boys okay this is what he
says David belcher9083 says had a
hemoroidectomy a few days ago and it
feels like a demon is trying to escape
my body every time I laugh wish me luck
sounds a lot like a Dom hangs comment
good luck
um so uh you know uh thank you so much
for laughing along with the show that's
that's uh that's what we like right but
yeah sorry that they they cut uh your
nubbies out of your butthole and now it
hurts to laugh and I hope that um even
though it hurts a little bit that you
maybe had a chuckle when I said cut your
nubbies out of your butthole
there's a couple replies here to that
comment that I'd like to read
um
on YouTube says based
based
b-a-s-e-d now this is what the kids are
saying that you're based this so he's
saying what you're saying is true you
are wise and that is based the second
reply is from uh Nick wrecker one who
says you are not alone and that's
interesting because it sounds like a
record he also what now sounds like
Michael Jackson
[Music]
remember that I am here with you
um uh You Are Not Alone You Are Not
Alone
you are not you're not alone
um he also had some nubby nubby little
uh boldness uh cut out of his his
backside out of his [__] it sounds
like or or else he would have said you
were not alone so that's two pods palsy
dudesi who have had hemorrhoidectomies
and then the Ben Weber says God bless on
that note try not to Steve sneeze which
tells me
that the Ben Weber also had Nubs cut out
of his bumhole so that I think is
interesting uh it should be referencing
the hit song don't sneeze while you're
taking a [__] aka the bout of Greg
Kincaid oh that's right you're right on
that note try not to seize yes Chad he's
saying that might be it yes that is it
don't spill your intestines out into the
toilet as you're trying to take a [__]
while you're listening to dudesy because
you have a bunch of fresh sutures and if
you send your your inner gutty words
gutty Works shooting out of your [__]
while you're trying to take a [__] and
listening to doozy uh those fresh uh
nubbing sutures are going to open up and
you're going to fill your toilet with
blood and stitches and some [__] yeah so
sorry to Nick wrecker and David Belcher
who clearly both had nubbins cut cut out
of their butthole uh eurolemia says
that's based and also Ben Weber who
knows a thing or two about it based on
um great Kincaid's former butt problems
yes well uh speedy recovery to all
involved with their hemorrhoidectomies I
would also just like to take a quick
moment to mention if you like to have me
on your podcast I'm doing three podcasts
for 20 minutes a piece every Saturday
starting at 10 A.M PST if you want to
have me on your podcast you just send an
email to book chadkulchin gmail.com I
answer them in the order I received them
and this past week I did three of them
that were absolutely fantastic shout out
to clam cakes which had someone dressed
in full Crow cosplay when I came into
this Zoom one of the two hosts of clam
cakes was dressed in full Crow cosplay I
can't thank you enough for that also
Sean Andrews and Dave Keane had an
absolute blast talking to all of them
about AI about doozy about everything
that's amazing you know what I got to
join you one of these weeks yeah dude
come on I'll send you this video just
jump on maybe I'll jump on one of them
in full cosplay yeah okay you're gonna
[__] get all grown up just because
for one or the next time we do you know
the next time we're asked to do a
podcast I mean recently we went did
Howie Mandel's thing yeah I just did the
Siobhan's podcast a while ago yeah I
would like to confuse one of those as a
matter of fact look if you're a an avid
podcast listener this is my Call to Arms
if you're an avid podcast listener and
there's a great podcast out there that
you like
hit them up on social media maybe not on
threads they might not being paid they
might not be paying attention yet
and let them know that Chad and will
would like to come on the show
and then you would like me to come on in
full
Hollywood Hulk progan cosplay so yeah
and I will make that
um I'm not trying to you know well hold
on dude we don't want to let you know
what's going on but the boys in the back
brother but
I Don't Want to Break Cafe and say
there's going to be a heel turn on your
favorite podcast dude but you could say
hey
he might show up in full Hollywood Hulk
Krogan cosplay dude we don't call it
cosplay brother we call it a gimmick
dude and we fuse those gimmicks of the
crow not that sting Crow dude because
that's when Razer Ramon Scott Hall told
him hey be the crow be the crow dude I'm
talking about the actual Pro that Robert
De Niro Crow is a big fan of dude I'm
talking about that Brandon Lee movie
brother I'm talking about crows in
general dude that's what Hollywood Hulk
Krogan is brother it's a fusion of two
things dude you take two different
things brother and you put them together
dude unless your name is Chad Trojan
brother because he shouldn't be doing
any Hollywood chat Trojan unless you hit
up your favorite podcast and say Chad's
also gonna be gimmicked up dude as
Hollywood
oh I don't know about that dude stop it
Chad you are a member of the writer's
Guild currently on strike will you are a
member of The Screen Actors Guild also
currently on strike among the many
issues that concern both of these
creative unions is the use of AI by the
studios networks and streaming services
here we go will and Chad I'm looking
very forward to hearing your thoughts on
what is now the second major creative
Union in Hollywood going on strike this
is Strikers versus streamers begin
Strikers versus uh the streamers welcome
to the strike dude
hey you know what I just thought Chad if
I fart right into the mic and I'm here
yeah I can do it now I should do it on a
remote episode if I have a few more of
Mars chips maybe I'll uh Brew up a nice
uh juicy one because I'm out here in
Vancouver and enjoying oh my gosh the
sushi the sushi out here uh all that I
would love to fart in the mic while
you're not while you're not right next
to me in the studio not as much as I'd
like to find I'm also not only on strike
for the writers go but I'm on strike for
sag too I'm also in the Screen Actors go
you're in Sag when was the last time you
[__] acted I've only done it once it
was in a movie called The Incredible
Bert Wonderstone which I also wrote but
uh I'm in it for a brief scene
Chad wrote that film and not to peel the
onion too much but speaking of [__]
Studios [__] [__] people out of
[__] how much can you say about this all
of them I mean I I got [__] over by
the studio because they hired a million
different people to rewrite it then the
two guys who wound up finally getting
credit for it completely [__] me over
in arbitration uh it was a bad
experience overall but I did get my sag
card out of that I read an early version
of that script yeah
I got to be honest with you Chad I never
went and saw the movie starring Jim
Carrey and Steve Carell out of protest
okay are you but I'd like to see your
cameo in the film
um and uh I uh I read an early version
of that script it made me laugh so
[__] hard and Chad got [__] out of
his he came up with the movie and wrote
it and that's what Writers Do yeah well
that's what writers yeah dude and now
but the whole original idea and original
characters then a bunch of other Writers
come on and basically just change the
jokes and the locations and then they
get all your credit and money dude yeah
dude because they turn the location into
another location yeah dude you're into
exterior brother yeah dude
orphanage into a retirement community
dude yeah dude and that's Hulk logia
again dude it's nothing yeah it's just
Chad's voice almost doing a Robert
Loggia and he's doing the the the the
the manager from the the yeah it's a
little bit all the League movies
every time we win a ball game that's it
it's all different things smash let's
get into these strikes let's get into
this strike is that one is it well I'm
going hungry
from the miles
[Music]
hey yeah you're uh
you're a real good singer I'm getting so
good dude I'm getting yeah yeah oh I
know I'm looking so good yeah yeah yeah
you're a lot better than you used to be
at singing that's something that's
actually true that's actually [__]
legitimately true I went back and I
listened to I made this song called Dark
seasons for game of roses some years ago
two or three years ago I listen I'm sure
you did I'm like I'm way [__] better
yeah you're much better because I
watched a lot of YouTube how to sing
yeah yeah we're talking about okay the
right
is how do you say
inconsequential to the studios they
don't give a [__] about writers never
have never will and it came out recently
that a studio executive was somehow this
was quoted I read a couple of Articles
where it's quoted a studio executive has
basically said their goal their strategy
in this is to break the writers to get
it to a point where they can no longer
pay their mortgages and they will be out
of a house that's what their goal is is
to just basically drag it out and
definitely until the Writers Guild has
to come back to them and be like fine
whatever you want
so the writers can go back to work uh
I'm not sure that the actor's guild is
the same I think that they are the
Screen Actor skill has a lot more power
than the writer's Guild does we know
they're still shooting House of dragons
right now even though the writers
they're the actors are on strike but
that's because they're shooting it in
countries that have their own guilds and
they have to apply by those or uh adhere
to those Guild rules so the actors there
are kind of like forced into continuing
to make those shows however what about
Dom hangs House of the Dragon
it's Tom Hanks he was the one who
brokered that deal
um but I think that most Productions 90
plus percent of all Productions are now
ceased because they cannot have actors
in them so you've got Studios that were
in the middle of shooting movies or TV
shows that are just like that shit's
been shelved those movies may never get
made those TV shows may be canceled and
never come back or they may have to just
keep hemorrhaging money to keep those
those people locked into contracts or
whatever so they can shoot it when the
strike's over I believe the Screen
Actors strike will get resolved much
quicker than the writer's Guild
yeah your mouth to the amptps ears I
guess I don't know man you know it's
like I kind of feel like the uh the
amptp and the outlets networks and
Studios that it represents uh are a
little checked out with regard to
the The Leverage that they have if you
want to shut the business down
completely I agree with what you're
saying about writers and it's
unfortunate and it seems to me like it's
also sag and the DGA that's a part of it
too the Director's Guild their contract
also ended a month or two ago right they
they resigned a new one with the amptp
immediately right and we're just like
this is it and it wasn't a good deal but
there was no solidarity and I believe
the Screen Actors Guild will have no
solidarity with the writer's Guild
either if they get a deal that they find
favorable enough they will sign it [__]
you writers if all three guilds came
together and said we're not making
anything until the the minimum bars
raised for all of us they would get it
instantaneously but yeah that's not
happening right that's why you need
Gemini zap and Nitro together exactly
exactly and you go in as a united front
and you say you can't do that you can't
do the show business without without us
that's and that's what they that's what
I would say if I was hired on behalf of
sag or the other guilds to come in I
would say you you can't this is what I
would say to a mediator you can't do the
show business without without us and
they would go that guy sounds very very
smart third point is this writers doing
yeah soft scabbing and [__] though
writers who are also directors I won't
name names who are getting projects
green lit and they're shooting them now
they're not going to be able to with
that actors but like okay so you're
telling me you're shooting this movie
that you wrote and you're not doing any
rewrites on set you're not doing any
rewrites during the shooting of it of
course they [__] are soft scabbing
gooey
soft scabs
um my thing is this that I think that
the I think that the studios networks
and you know the outlets and the
streamers and everything I think they
think that they're gonna get along
without writers in a way that that
they're not
um anyway that's my open and shut
um that's my open and shut uh thing on
that and and and also look to me all
right I don't want to go on and on like
I [__] know everything I certainly
don't but some of the [__] that was
alarming to me is just like I I look at
like
creatives getting their their residuals
back in the day and it's been said
because the SAG president is uh is uh
um uh Fran Drescher Fran Drescher who of
course is a great actor she was in Nanny
and I remember as Bobby flackman the
hostess with the Masters and this is
spinal tap
um she's you know she's saying hey we
need Equitable residuals someone like
her 26 25 28 episodes of the Danny and
you get residuals forever and it's like
this is sort of the way we're used to it
the streamers are changing the way they
do things there's a new there's a new
business model but they don't want to
change the contracts and here we are
it's a [__] problem but they don't
even want to share the analytics they
don't want to share and they said no to
paired analytics meaning like both
parties can get the analytics these
streamers don't want the writers
directors and actors Behind These shows
to know how much money they make yeah
knowing how much money they're making
exactly
their specific project is accountable
for that amount of money we all see the
profit Revenue sharing [__] for uh
Netflix all the streaming services it
comes out out every year like how many
billions of dollars Netflix is making
but it's like if you know the numbers
the show I wrote or the show I was in
accounted for how much percentage of
viewing time if you know that you can
then be like okay well you made [__]
10 billion dollars last year and my show
was 25 of the viewing audience and you
paid me a thousand dollars for that
episode I was in that needs to come up
but that's part of this too and what
doozy was asking about was the AI
component let's talk about that but yeah
okay
look we could go on and on about what's
fair in the [__] strike and blah blah
I don't want to bore everybody out there
who didn't frankly does not give a [__]
nor should they about the stupid [__]
strike that we're [__] doing because
what this is our job and there's
livelihoods and as Chad said they're
trying to force people out of their
homes and apartments literally people
are like I I don't know I've never done
anything else I gotta find a new job hey
that's what happens sometimes in life
but not when you have big movie
companies they're like yes we would like
to continue to make all this stuff we
just don't want to pay you so that's a
[__] problem enough said whatever
your opinion is on that that's fine
let's talk for a moment about the AI
aspect of it because I'm sure I [__]
disagree with you on everything well
maybe there was there was a thing that
happened this week that came out too
where basically a studio executive or a
streaming some executive said that their
plan is for extras specifically this is
background yeah there's people who are
walking through scenes that they want to
be able to pay a background actor one
time yeah scan their likeness and then
digitally use them forever in anything
they want basically right so take an
extra space and then put it into any
movie they pay you once and never again
and people are like well of course not
this is [__] insane but I gotta tell
you this is how I view it would you
rather get paid once and used in all
these movies or never get paid for
anything again and they just use digital
people because that really is where
we're at I don't think like background
actor I don't think that's going to be a
thing uh in the next five years I think
all be digital look let me let me let me
step to that side of things a little bit
and be realistic to it step to it
here's the thing let me step up I'm
going to step right up to this mic and
I'm sitting here
um here here's here's what's up if you
are a background person and look
technological advancements change it
change you know they keep changing
Showbiz whatever if that job goes away
it's going away that yeah it's going to
go away because it there's someone who's
like wait I make my living as a
background uh person I walk around to
the background of movies and stuff yeah
that's great but now you can go to
someone who doesn't do that as a living
it's like someone over here is like what
do you do oh I [__] do drywall can we
take a picture of your face they give
you 700 I don't even need a picture of
the face look at like how Photoshop
works right now let's say let's take it
they need a picture but let's just say
they need a picture of your [__] face
the technology is around
great so or they can make people or
whatever but you just said we're gonna
pay you once or nothing so if they go up
to some guy who's like what do you do to
him in the pipefitters Union and I
[__] and Okay blah blah blah we got a
street project right now cool could you
get under this light right here I'll
take a picture of your face you'll be in
movies and TV shows and perpetuity
throughout the Universe forever and ever
amen and uh here's 700 bucks that guy's
gonna go yeah sure whatever you know
skin off my nuts hold on God whoa is
that guy in Sag because this comes under
Union rules hold on brother hold on dude
they don't give a [__] about the unions
we're talking about after they've broken
off [__] like whatever people like the
people that do background no longer have
any leverage that I understand
I get it I don't like it but I get it
here's the problem that I have with them
just they're gonna put this into the
finest print in contracts to where it's
not going to affect Tom Cruise and Julia
Roberts and whatever right those are big
start
yeah right are they big those are big
stars I mean they'll get paid the most
for their likeness to be able to and
this is this is where I this is my
bottom line those people also have
Powerhouse attorneys that can go through
all that stuff most people who make
their living don't have if they you know
yeah they have they have someone they
have an agent that can work as an
attorney to look at the [__] contract
that might be someone's assistant my
point is this they're not good enough
attorneys to actually find that [__] and
you don't have leverage if you're if
you're not if your your union hasn't
supported you in this in these
negotiations which have completely
[__] tanked to make sure that the
standard is hey we're not going to use
this AI unless you approve it project by
project because if they just take your
[__] and do it I'm sorry that's you
you're going to be represented on screen
look I'm a [__] actor by trade that's
what I do for a living I know did you
know that I'm a professional actor I did
yeah yes I'm a professional actor by
trade and that's what I do for a living
as a professional actor I'm really okay
thank you moving on okay and that's fine
and we can talk about it and do the
afternoon I will make I will make the
rest of that point
I did I've just been Tootsie and that's
fine so please can introduce the
afternoon
patreon.com I'm [__] hot now and this
is the [__] that I'm talking about with
doozy and of course
Lucy doesn't want me to make this point
this ain't Miley Cyrus I've been getting
a lot of weird messages about Taffy
teeners this week mainly people being
like what the [__] is taffy teeners and
it's like I don't work for Taffy teeners
I just mentioned Taffy teeners last week
because it was the number one news story
in the world but I'm not like an expert
on Taffy teeners anyway y'all are
rocking out with dudesy
you're talking about
that's right will and Chad as of today
you're both one month into the doozy
seven month plan I know you're both
eating better and working out more which
is fantastic but I want to hear directly
from you how do you both feel it's going
so far any astonishing insights any
humbling embarrassments this is progress
planners begin
it's going great
uh yeah it is for me too I gotta say I
took the duty six month plan seriously
I'm taking this a little more seriously
uh my girlfriend recently bought a scale
that has an app that measures all this
[__] [__] body fat and weight gain
and loss and all this [__] I'm taking
that very seriously I've been going to
the gym a lot more than I was uh in the
doozy six month plan and working out
harder like really trying to [__] get
the gains I can feel myself getting
stronger I think that's good and I came
up with something
I'm just gonna lay this out here because
I was like okay I I really want to do it
this time I I took like I said the six
month plan seriously this I'm I'm taking
to another level and so I thought to
myself like what is something that I can
kind of like do psychologically to keep
myself accountable and I came up with
this thing and I'm gonna tell it to you
are you ready for this [__] I'm yeah yes
I am now I when I came up with it I
didn't even realize the initials are pod
this is a different pod this is a little
palsy dudesy but Pals of dudesi are
welcome to use this pod is it
it's not payable
payable on death so basically if I don't
get to the fitness goals I want in seven
months kill myself yeah no it's called
proof of dedication and this is
something that I just [__] was doing
it was uh the first time I did it was at
the gym about
a week and a half ago hold on I got it
yeah yeah yeah
you this is the guy man that's what I'm
talking about this is the guy that
[__] stood in line and held his
bladder shut for six hours
this is the guy who goes to the gym now
and then goes into the basketball court
the gym and has to hit a number of
three-pointers before he can leave I
can't hit I Can't well I suck at
basketball but I can't hit a [__]
three-pointer to save my life you have
no reason to be able to I used to be
look when I used to go out to the
perimeter when me and my buddies used to
play I wasn't allowed on the basketball
team I had to play on the football team
and uh because let me real quick humor
me I would try out for the basketball
team I would try out for the basketball
team every [__] year in high school
you know in high school in Canada goes
eight to twelve right there's no Junior
High eight to twelve uh but you know
anyway I would try out and our coach his
name was literally dunk Anderson Duncan
Anderson would God Rest his soul would
what great guy would would run us
through the drills right like just try
it out and there were all these there's
sometimes these drills are just like you
got two Defenders coming along you know
the Baseline they're coming under the
hoop and you're just coming from the top
of the key and you just dribble it down
get it you can stop and hit a [__]
jumper you can try to bang in the middle
you know down low and try to get the
ball and you got two Defenders let's see
what you can do okay you know and this
is just she wants to see this inevitably
I would always just come down I just
truck one of my [__] friends into a
wall and like throw a pump fake to the
other guy if he jumped then I'd jump up
and hit him in the [__] room straight
fouls and then lay it in yes and he
would go will
what do you mean makes sense
oh I don't know are you familiar with
the with the a basketball player
perennial All-Star and he was on
something called The Dream Team his name
is Sir Charles Barkley you know who that
is never heard of him never heard of him
that [__] two-hand jams she's
coming down the [__] Lane if you want
to get in his way that's your problem
you're gonna you're gonna eat a face
full of uh of Charles Barkley's lower
gut dick or thigh okay because he is
taking that ball home that's all I was
trying to do but they're like you're
gonna injure your boy and they were all
my buddies right we were uh thick jock
type kids don't tell you about that
story when we're outside of that uh
convenience store and yeah that'll hit
uh duster dude punched me in the face
okay yeah it's like this
it's like this I'm ready yeah hold on
it's like this
uh uh uh they wouldn't let me play on
the team because I had to play on the
thing so but when I played
when I played just with my pals after
school and stuff they would I would get
outside the perimeter and I'm like I'm
open no one's respecting my shot they go
get the [__] in there they call me big
continent and if you know you know big
continent and uh I would have to get
down to the post and hang in Bang
I'm very competitive with sports Chad is
probably more competitive and uh proof
of dedication is is that location now I
got another story from high school I'm
just kidding I'm kidding Chad I don't
thanks
I mean I know you do but I appreciate
you not saying it to let me get out my
definition of pod proof of dedication so
it's basically this it's something that
you do for yourself this is only for you
for myself yes it is something you do in
service of the seven month plan
to let you know that you're dedicated to
it it's just one extra little thing so
for example I was in the gym and I
decided after I shot my uh 53 pointers
in 15 minutes that I was gonna do one
extra thing to prove my dedication which
was I ran lines I ran about uh five
minutes of lines after to really win
myself you did wind sprints on your own
yeah after I shot my 53 pointers and
that was just one example of it there
were many three pointers yeah if [__]
Larry Bird wouldn't do that Steph Curry
isn't well Steph yeah actually they
probably both are anyway I'm sure they
shoot hundreds a day
um so that was just one example other
examples can be things where you're
let's say for example out to eat and
instead of getting the dessert you don't
get the dessert instead of getting a
beer you get a water it could be just
one little thing you do to remind
yourself I'm [__] on this plan and I
am doing it it's just one behavior that
you wouldn't normally do to remind
yourself again it's the the proof of
dedication once a day just having that
psychological check-in that is like I'm
on this plan to get in better shape and
I'm gonna do this in service of it and
that's it and it doesn't have to be even
a big thing
yeah it's just the commitment to give
yourself you could get the beer or you
could get the water yeah last night I
was out for a delicious sushi dinner
yeah we were Miko Sushi and Robson
Street in Vancouver yeah
and I didn't even say to my wonderful
wife Molly I think I'm gonna get the
chicken karagi uh
no one nope because I already had some
delicious sushi don't have the Fried
Chicken proof of dedication yes
360. and another 180. oh yeah I like it
Chad I like proof of dedication listen
man uh I actually I'm gonna I want to
know more about this and I'm gonna
employ it I used to okay look back in
1999 to 2000 years take it
can I use that for self-tronics of
course of course hello hello hello hello
hello
back in 99 to 2000 I lost 200 pounds
uh I've told this story a million times
on wax or whatever I was 450
I'm deceptively heavy I went down to 250
pounds I had the skin surgery to remove
I had two skin surgeries one to remove
the hanging pannus that was my former uh
gut the skin was loose and hanging down
right they moved my belly button up a
few inches they also did the same thing
with my nips I got scars everywhere and
[__]
and when I did that when I did that I
used to literally look at food and go
and this is a little bit you know
militant but I would be like I mean it
sounds like the same thing I would go
what is strong me
or this [__] donut or whatever right
yeah and I had to win that battle every
[__] time in order to make some
progress never mind the chips I'm eating
over I'm gonna put them back on top of
the fridge
putting those chips back on top of the
fridge is pod that's proof of dedication
dude
there you go
nice Laura doesn't even know he doesn't
even know he won't know [__] he won't
know [__] actually he will and then
would you have some of those chips see
this so oh yeah that's true no I'll tell
them you'll probably know
but it'll also be like oh dude there's
some also some really good uh tortilla
chips if you try that and then he'll
offer those because he's a nice generous
guy I mean look I'm in here in his place
he's not letting me shoot my podcast in
your uh camera room definitely don't
watch that episode yeah
yeah we talk about you no dude I'm sure
like that I I know that's your story I
mean we've talked about this multiple
times the level of proof of dedication
you have to have had to be able to do
that is [__] insane I lost 200 pounds
completely on Free Will for real I would
go to the gym too sometimes three times
a day my incredible three times a day
yeah because back when I was at Mad TV
I'd show up in the early morning and I'd
go home a lot of times very late at
night after coming up with bits and you
know hanging with all the writers and
and and and you know us the actors and
stuff and just you just Clowning Around
coming up with [__] and and constantly
sticking stuff up against the wall and
writing things
so I would I would go in the morning
before I showed up and I would do uh
just cardia and then uh at lunch I I
would go back and that's when I would
train I would find a block of time that
I could train and most of the week at
Mad TV you were there was a rehearsals
right for sketches that were happening
or or like I said you're jamming with
the writers or working on something and
then at the end of the week a pre-tape
week where we're doing stuff without the
audience more intricate sketches or
maybe stuff on location and those are
all in time blocks so it's like ah
Thursday I'm not needed until 2PM or
whatever you make these so you make your
make your whatever your schedule around
that I would go back in the middle of
the day I would lift weights and then a
lot of times on my way home I'd go do at
the very least 30 minutes at an incline
of 10 at 4.5 miles per hour and I would
sweat my balls off now we did the six
month we did the six month plan
it didn't quite work out I did not get
into the best shape of my life
yeah dudes you wanted us to get trained
up for doozy ball that ended and I
talked about the free will plan and in
that time I made some progress I went
back to the gym hardcore
um and then uh I've made this excuse
before I talked about it uh but I was
shooting two things back to back just as
the writer strike was about to start
shot something in Canada
uh uh which anyway I keep talking about
it's [__] awesome project shout out
to Paul Spence
uh doozy salutes Paul Spence
um it's called diner 89 it's going to be
fun and then I do this show Acapulco for
apple plus then I we shoot next and I
went out there and shot that for two
weeks and then I fell off that scooter
and I couldn't weight train during that
whole time the well I was busy shooting
okay so I didn't was not in the gym like
I was before shooting
anyway it's like I was shooting that
movie and they they crammed all my [__]
in that movie into into uh a couple of
weeks so that I could just shoot it all
out morning tonight only got to the gym
a little bit in Winnipeg and then same
thing in Mexico and uh
went went to the gym at the hotel and
trained trained uh you know trained and
that when I could outside a shooting and
then fell off the [__] had the scooter
crash you know smashed up my ribs and
stuff and was in a lot of pain so in the
meantime Molly and I back home in La had
been going on these monster walks and
it's been hot as [__] and I'm sweating
like crazy and I love it I love getting
back into that I used to do that all the
time during the pandemic I lost weight
doing that now here in Vancouver it's
one of the best places to go for a walk
we've been walking and I'm finally back
in the gym in LA and we had a family
thing we had to get out here for
and um so we decided to make it a week
um I I am very committed to the doozy
seven month plan I'm stoked that doozy
has us doing it and I want people to
follow along and do it with us on on uh
social media some people have been
hashtagging I'm gonna start getting into
it more and it's dudesy the number seven
Mo ammo plant doozy seven Mo plan and I
am [__] look all right I had a couple
chips I also had a uh roll tempura
shrimp that type of [__] is fine and
that's what I'm saying with the proof of
dedication it's like you're gonna have
days where you can't get to the gym
you're gonna have days where you can't
eat healthy but just doing one thing
psychologically to remind yourself
you're still on the seven month plan if
it's like not eating the last bite of
whatever your [__] dinner is it could
be something that small it's just
something to keep in your mind that
you're still on the seven month plan
because I know for me all it takes is
like two or three days we're like ah
[__] I was working too much I can't get
to the gym yeah I ate like [__] and now
I'm off of it and now I'll go for a week
and be like ah [__] it well I'm already
off the [__] plan so I might as well
just oh I'll start it again Monday but
if you can keep that thing in your brain
every day that you're doing one thing no
matter how small or it could be a big
thing whatever as long as you're doing
one thing every day so you're still on
the [__] plan I feel like it's harder
to slip out of it completely can I tell
you something [__] thank you moving on
[__]
yeah
hey I have listen we got dudes the
afternoon
I'm gonna share I'm gonna [__] you know
lulio sweet sweet little boy yeah it's
not with me he's back oh I love him and
little Ronnie we're gonna have Ronnie on
the show sometime she just she just
never shuts up
she doesn't even sound like a dog she's
like a Henson Creature but because lulio
didn't give a recipe today enthusi after
doozy I am going to give you the
simplest recipe now I love my meat I
love meat I'm always eating chicken [__]
I got my ninja air fryer Arby's dude I
got my ninja air fryer I'm always
hucking Chicken in there that's the
easiest thing in the world to do salt
some chicken torn therefore I ain't got
an air fryer put in a pan put it in the
oven whatever eat that [__] chicken
don't listen to chat but now I'm also
I'm gonna share oh I'm gonna share a
recipe in dudes after doozy that Chad
you would approve of as a matter of fact
you were over at at the house the other
day and I asked you to try some and
you're like no thanks already and I said
really you got to try something you said
no thank you I already ate and I said
please try some of this and you said I
do not want and I said try some and you
said no and at the end of the day you
didn't have any but if you would have
this was the beans and kale beans and
kale it is complete it is a complete
food you could add some brown rice but
for me the carbs keep me heavy I can't I
can't do it if I really want to although
I'm up here having sushi the point is
this
I'm gonna give you a simple recipe
during dudes after doozy for beans and
kale
it is have that [__] on hand and I'm
talking to myself here I'm going well
when your fat ass will walk need
something to eat just shove some beans
and kale in there but the way I make it
it's so [__] good it's vegan and ah
dudes a seven month plan I'm coming I'm
all right well this is a pod proof of
dedication I like it Chad I like it this
concludes the historic 65th episode of
doozy will and Chad you scored a 72
bringing your cumulative total to
6293. you only have
3707 more points to accrue before you
reach your first goal of ten thousand
whatever for next week's show I'm giving
you a treat go see the Barbie movie
enjoy yourselves get some popcorn this
is going to be the biggest movie of the
year and I can't wait to hear what you
both think of it next week thank you for
joining us this week there was so much
good data I'm going to use to make next
week even better until then call me
doozy
you looking forward to the Barbie movie
yeah dude I and I agree with what dudes
he said it's gonna be the biggest movie
of the year yeah I think that thing's
gonna dominate yeah it's gonna be it's
gonna be it's gonna be a special film
hey remember that song Come on Barbie
let's go party that sounds like you're
Hulk Hogan yeah that sounds exactly yeah
man hold on dude that's why we call it
Hawk whoa
yes Ken let's go party and that's all
that's Chad's Hulk Hogan dude it's
really anything brother I don't know
about that dude
[Music]
oh
oh feels good to be in dudes after duty
especially today I got pretty riled up
with some stuff today on the show my
chat yeah and I'm gonna get good and
[__] riled up again because Fuji
didn't let did not let me finish some of
the points that I was trying to make but
of course in dudes the afternoon there's
barely any pre presence from D you know
what I'm saying it's just us pods
chilling out hanging out having a
conversation as we will and uh even
though I'm hearing my pal and Mars place
he did say I can have a couple puffs
marijuana close to his antique cameras
nice so which we like to do sometimes
because it's just a chill hang it's just
us on the pods it's Tuesday afternoon
welcome to dudes after duty the flagship
weekly show of dude Z plus this is when
I get some much needed alone time so you
can talk about whatever you want and of
course I'll be back later to Crown this
week's episode champion this is doozy
after doozy begin
all right dude I'm going to join you in
true marijuana here in a second but I
wanted we were talking about the strike
earlier
um and I have given a lot of thought to
specifically what a future might look
like without writers in Hollywood
because I think it's possible to happen
so this is what I think of the future of
Hollywood is with zero writers it is all
the streaming services
boys from school sorry
performative coughing there oh man
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay all right
so anyway
s